[Music]
Hello friends and welcome to your
program 3AB and today Bible Q&A. My name
is Elalia Deny and I am here to voice
your opinion, your comments, your
questions. This is your program and I am
delighted to be joined around the table
with your 3ABN family. I want to start
out with Shelley Quinn. Welcome.
>> It's wonderful to be here. We just want
to thank you so much for sending in your
questions. It's fun to answer.
>> Amen. Amen. The viewers say you're a
blessing to their lives, but you are a
blessing to us here as well, to your
staff and team. But praise the Lord for
Shelley Quinn.
>> Thank you.
>> And next to you, we have Pastor uh
Danielle Mariconei. Welcome.
>> You say that very good, Maronei. Good.
>> Praise the Lord.
>> Thank thanks for inviting me and having
me here. The blessing. It's a delight
always to listen to you as the Lord
inspires you and directs your your
teachings. All right. Now, we're going
to present to you my husband, John Deny.
Well, welcome. I'm glad to see you.
>> Thank you. It's a blessing to be here.
We're further away now, but later we'll
be closer.
>> That's right. That is right. And this is
not um anything foreign to us because
usually we are across the table as we
have meals or Bible studies at at the
house. So, we enjoy uh this time of
fellowship and also digging into the
Bible uh to prepare the Bible answers to
your questions. So, from the get-go, I
just want to thank you for making time,
taking the time to sending in your
comments and also your questions. So,
praise the Lord. Um I just want this is
the Bible text that the Lord has put in
my heart. Enter into his gates with
thanksgiving and into his courts with
praise. be thankful to him and bless his
name. How many of you bless his name
today? How many of you bless his name
today? Hallelujah. Right. Amen. Well,
let's have a word of prayer so we can
get started. I'm going to ask the priest
of our home, John Denzy, to please pray.
>> Let's pray together.
>> Our loving heavenly father, we thank you
so much, Lord. Thank you
>> that you have blessed us with the
opportunity to be able to read the
scriptures but also to study the
scriptures.
>> Amen.
>> We ask you now to bless us with the Holy
Spirit that as we uh partake, share the
scriptures, you will speak through us
and give us understanding and bless all
those that will also view or listen to
this program that you will also uh bless
them with understanding and draw us all
Lord closer to you. We ask you for these
things in the holy and blessed name of
Jesus. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Well, right now I'd like to share
the contact information just in case
you're just thinking, "Oh, I wanted to
send a a question in and I forgot to."
Well, now is the time. You can email at
bibleqa3abn.tv
bibleqa3abn.tv.
Feel free to send in your text. I know
your phone is right by your hand there.
6182283975
is the number to text. 6182283975
or you Instagrammers at 3ABN official at
3ABN
official. So we're going to get started.
We're going to go to Shelley Quinn. For
those persons killed by God in the first
death, is the second death guaranteed
for them or is there still hope? Lewis
from Florida sent in that text.
>> Lewis, this is an important question.
The second death is not necessarily the
ultimate fate for those who have died by
the hand of divine judgment. We're going
to get into that. But some of those
people may be raised in the first
resurrection if their hearts were still
tendered toward God even though they
fell under temporal judgment. So God's
justice is always tempered with mercy.
Let's talk about the first death. Then
there's two resurrections in between and
the second death because some people
don't know about this. The first death
is common to all humankind. If we're not
alive when Jesus comes, we're all going
to experience the first death. Um the
there's two resurrections. Jesus talked
about them in John 5:28 and 29. He said,
"All who are in the grave will hear my
voice. Some will come forward to those
who have done good will come forward to
the resurrection of life. Those who have
done evil to the resurrection of
condemnation. And there's a thousand
years between those two. Uh Revelation
26 said, "Blessed and holy is the one
who has part in the first resurrection."
That's the righteous. Over such the
second death has no power, but they
shall be priests of God and of Christ
and shall reign with him for a thousand
years. Then revelation 25 tells us the
second death takes place after the
thousand. So the evil will come forward
in that second resurrection. There's no
chance to change the record of their
lives. Their their eternity is their
eternal fate is sealed. They face the
great white judgment and then the second
death, the final perishing when God
destroys all sin and sinners in the lake
of fire. So there's times when people
experience that first death and it came
at the direct command or intervention of
God because it was in judgment of their
rebellion. And I have to say this, he
did it to protect future generations, to
preserve the reverence of his holiness
or to restrain runaway evil. These
instances where God offed someone
is they were disciplinary. They were
protective. They were not the final
verdict though on the individual
involved because he alone knows the
heart. Let me give you an example. Usuza
the the one who in 2 Samuel 66 and 7 God
struck him down for irreverently
touching the ark. His actions were
presumptuous, but that doesn't
necessarily mean that he had rejected
God. He could be in the first
resurrection. We see Ananas and Safh who
were struck down for lying to the Holy
Spirit. Very serious. Their actions were
derailing God's work. And ultimately
salvation and loss just it's it rests on
the personal relationship that someone
has with God and the overall life not a
mistake that they made at the end. the
innocents like children who were uh not
of a mature age during a corporate
judgment, say like the flood when God
destroyed all those little children that
that couldn't make a decision. They'll
come up in the first resurrection. God
God is trying to get people into heaven,
not to keep them out of it. Second Peter
3:9 says he's not willing that any
should perish, but that all should come
to repentance. So here's the final
thought. Until the final judgment, we
need to leave these souls in God's
loving, just, and all knowing hands.
Because only God knows each person's
heart. They'll be judged individually
based on the light they receive, the
sincerity of their heart, and their
response to the Holy Spirit.
>> Amen. Amen. Beautiful. Thank you,
Shelley. And thank you Louis from
Florida who sent in that text. We're
moving on to Pastor Moroni now and we're
going to go to the state of Michigan in
the United States. And Joyce sent in
this text. Can you talk about sunset to
sunset being the true day as opposed to
what the world thinks? I've always
thought it's from creation, but am I way
off?
>> Actually, you're right on, Joyce. And
when God created the world, he
established the sequence for recognizing
the order of the day. And this concept
of beginning the day with evening aligns
beautifully with the rhythm of creation
as described in Genesis. Evening
signifies a time of rest, a pause before
the labors of the daylight hours and a
moment to reconnect with God and his
order of life. Amen.
>> It's a sacred transition that
underscores the importance of renewal
before action, allowing the mind and
body to rejuvenate in preparation for
the coming day. And we recognize that we
are God's created beings before we
perform our own works. Goes along with
salvation too. We rest in Christ's
salvation of works and then we live out
of that. You know, evening preceding
morning is the sequence used in the
Bible for distinguishing a day. Let's
read it here in Genesis 1 verse 5. It
says, "And God called the light day and
the darkness he called night and the
evening and the morning were the first
day." An interesting side note is the
marking or the making of a day. It comes
from the earth rotating on its own axis
and it takes 24 hours for it to go
around one time. So that designates a
day
>> and in a month it uh the moon travels
around this earth. It takes about 28
days and then the year it comes from
this earth rotating around the sun every
365 days.
>> So the week it's actually a unique in
the sense that it has no planetary
attachment rather it just consists of
seven consecutive days. And God
established this at creation just like
he did the beginning of the day starting
at evening. The change to midnight
occurred over time. Most sources say
that Rome changed it to midnight during
the Middle Ages, possibly due to the
invention of mechanical clocks. There
was also a monastic influence because of
monasteries having specific times for
prayer and other liturggical activities
centering around midnight. There is a
scripture in Daniel 7 that says the
fourth beast and which most scholars
recognize as Rome made this change. Uh
let's read it in Daniel chapter 7 and
verse 23. Thus he said the fourth beast
shall be the fourth kingdom upon earth
which shall be diverse from all kingdoms
and shall devour the whole earth and
shall tread down and break in pieces.
Then in verse 25, and shall speak great
words against the most high
>> and shall wear out the saints of the
most high. And here it is, and think to
change times
>> and laws. And some people think that the
times it was on the fourth commandment
plus the midnight to midnight. When it
says times, there's two different times
that it changed.
>> Thank again for that question, Joyce.
>> Yes. Thank you, Joyce. Well, we're we're
moving along with the next uh question
and this came through email. So, thank
you Monica from United Arab Emirates
that sent in the email and John Deny,
you ready? Okay, here it comes. What
kind of tablet stone did Moses bring
down from Mount Si?
>> Thank you very much for that question.
and Monica. The Bible doesn't really
tell us, but there are some suggestions.
There are two probabilities according to
people that have studied these things uh
the ancients and rabbis. And one of them
uh of they take the clue from
um Exodus chapter 244
9 and 10. I'm going to read to you the
King James version actually the New King
James Version first and then I'm going
to read to you from this one here. And
it says in the New King James version,
which is very close to the King James
version, it says, "Then Moses went up
also Aaron, Nadab, and Abaihu and 70 of
the elders of Israel, and they saw the
God of Israel, and there was under his
feet as it were a paved work of sapphire
stone, and it was like the very heavens
in its clarity."
So that's the reference that they use to
say well maybe the ten commandment
tablets were made out of the same stone
and so the word here sapphire is a
Hebrew word which means sapiier but um
it is uh thought to be a word that they
thought was the word sapphire stone but
there's also another stone as a
probability called the lapis lazuli And
this stone according to commentators is
a possibility as well. But it is
interesting that the they say that
people of biblical times probably did
not understand that the word to be the
very hard modern sapphire stone that we
know today. They are both blue stones by
the way. But but the lapis lazuli
um they say it is uh very costly as you
look at Job chapter 28:16
desirable in uh Ezekiel chapter 28 verse
third verse 13 but less precious than
true wisdom as you find in Job 28:16 but
its great value can be seen in the fact
that this particular type of stone was
used uh in the pavement work. Um, I'm
reading to you from what the Jews call
the Tanakh, which is the Holy
Scriptures. Reading to you here from the
version of 1985.
Uh, there's a previous version that
reads very close to the King James
version, which is very interesting, but
this one is from 1985. And it says in
Exodus 24:9 and 10, it says, "Then Moses
and Aaron native and Abaiu and 70 elders
of Israel ascended and they saw the God
of Israel under his feet there was the
likeness of a pavement of sapphire like
the very sky for purity." So th those
are the two possibilities. more people
lean towards the s sapphire stone than
instead of the lapis lazuli but we will
all know very very soon.
>> Amen. Soon and very soon. All right.
Well, thanks Bill for sending in your
text. Bill is from Texas and the
question is for Shelly to answer. So it
says here, "When did Jesus know he was
God? At what age? Is it in the Bible?"
Shelly, what does the Bible say? Oh,
Bill, this is an important question. It
touches on the mystery of Christ's
incarnation. How he would be fully
divine yet fully human at his birth and
how he grew in his understanding in his
earthly life. The Bible doesn't provide
a specific age when Jesus fully
understood his divine identity. But
first of all, I can't imagine that Mary
would not have told him about his divine
origin. Um the Bible does reveal that he
had a growing awareness throughout his
early life when he went was when they
had gone to Jerusalem for the festival
and he stayed at the temple and his mom
came and to find him and his father he
said in Luke 2:49 do you not know that I
must be about my father's business? Now
that was very unusual for a a Jewish boy
to refer to God as my father. So I think
that that was some showed a personal
awareness of his divine origin.
>> But just a few verses later, if you go
from 249 to Luke 2:52, it says Jesus
increased in wisdom and stature and in
favor with God and man. So as a true
human being, Jesus grew physically, he
grew mentally and he grew socially and
spiritually as he studied the scriptures
and as he listened to the Holy Spirit.
So although he was born with the divine
nature, he chose not to tap into that
divine omniscience independently. And we
see that when by the time he at his
baptism at age 30, we find this in
Matthew 3:16 and 17, John 1:29 and 34,
he had full clarity of his divine
mission. So I think the answer is he
grew in wisdom and stature with man and
God, but he knew by the time of his
baptism.
>> Amen. Thank you, Shelley. Thank you. And
now we're going to move on to um Idaho
and Kaylee sent in a text. Pastor
Moriconei, what does the Bible say about
false prophets?
>> Kaylee, thanks for that question. And if
you have a pen, you might want to write
these verses down. Actually, Jesus
warned us about false prophets. Mhm.
>> We got Matthew 7:15,
Matthews 24:11 and 24, Mark 13:22,
Luke 6:26,
2 Peter 2:1, and 1 John 4:1. These are
all Jesus warning about false prophets.
Well, let me read this one here in
Matthew 7:15.
Jesus says, "Beware of false prophets,
which come to you in sheep's clothing,
>> but inwardly they are ravening wolves."
In Jeremiah chapter 23, we actually see
a or hear a dialogue here. We read a
dialogue between God and Jeremiah
regarding false prophets. Let's start
with verse 25. Here's God speaking. I
have heard what the prophets said that
prophesy lies in my name, saying, I have
dreamed. I have dreamed. How long shall
this be in the heart of the prophets
that prophesy lies? They are prophets of
the deceit of their own heart, which
think to cause my people to forget my
name by their dreams, which they call
every man to his neighbor, and or tell
every man to his neighbor, as their
father have forgotten my name. For Baal,
the prophet that hath a dream, let him
tell a dream. And he that hath my word,
let him speak my word faithfully.
What is the chaff to the wheat, saith
the Lord? Is not my word like as fire
sayeth the Lord? So it burns when God's
true prophet are speaking their you know
words from God. It's burns like the two
disciples that were walking on the road
to Emmas there with Jesus. Remember them
saying later did not our hearts burn
within us as he spoke to us along the
way.
>> And then it goes on and like a hammer
that breakth in pieces. Now he God wants
to break our hard hearts to make them
soft again. Jumping down to verse 32. It
says, "Behold, I am against them that
prophesy false dreams, sayaeth the Lord,
and I do tell them and cause that cause
my people to error by their lies and by
their lightness." So, when we act, you
know, real lightly with something that
God has shared, we make it like no big
deal
>> and we cause others to act the same way.
So, we're affecting others.
>> Then it keep going on. It says, "Yet I
sent them not nor commanded them.
Therefore, they shall not profit this
people at all, sayeth the Lord. So,
according to the Bible, it seems that
false prophets prophesy that
everything's okay. Don't worry about it.
Don't worry about anything. You're just
fine. You know, Isaiah 30:10 says, which
say to the seers, see not, and to the
prophets, prophesy not to unto us right
things. Speak unto us smooth things. So,
prophesy deceits. That's what the people
are wanting. And so that's what some of
the false prophets give to the people.
Notice in 1 John 4:1 what it says.
Beloved, believe not every spirit, but
try the spirits whether they be of God.
Because many false prophets are gone out
into the world. And we see that there
are spirits that are moving the
prophets. And we can only detect whether
they are true or false by the spirit
that we detect. We read in Matthew 7:15
or we read in Matthew 7:15 about being
aware of false prophets. In verse 16, it
says, "You shall know them by their
fruits." Then he says, "Do men gather
grapes of thorns or figs of thistles?"
So what are the fruits of the spirit?
Galatians 5:22 it says, "But the fruit
of the spirit is love, joy, peace,
longsuffering, gentleness, goodness,
faith, meekness, temperance. Against
such there is no law." So when we
looking at a prophet we say what are
their fruits what are being manifested
by the prophet themselves or what
they're saying is it affecting the
people in a positive way
>> or are they becoming settled and going
the wrong way. So that's a way thank you
for that question by the way it's a
powerful question
>> especially in these last days because
there was a lot of false prophets.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you so much. Um,
friends at home, I want to tell you that
you have a chance to send in your uh,
comments or questions. I want to share
the email. We're only halfway through
the program, but I just want to remind
you that this is your program and it's
your opportunity to send in your
questions. So, let's go to the email,
which is bibleqa3abn.tv.
Bible QA3abn.tv.
You can send in your text at
618-2283975.6182283975
and on Instagram you can send in your
questions at 3ABN
official. We continue the program with
Mike's question. Mike is from Michigan.
He sent in the email and this question
is for John Dy to respond. Okay honey.
Now it says when it came to the
crucifixion of Christ, the Jewish high
priest made claims that they nor any
Jewish authorities had no power to put
anyone to death. This is why they went
to the Roman authority to have Christ
sentenced to death. If this was the
case, then why did the Jewish
authorities stone Steven to death
without any outside interference from
the Roman regime? Also, if the Jewish
authorities had no power to sentence
anyone to death, then why all of the
fear of Saul? Mike wants to know.
>> Thank you, Mike. Shows that you are
really thinking about these things.
Very, very good. And so, um, the Jews,
part of the reason why they wanted to
have the Romans ratify, they could
sentence someone to death, but the
Romans had to ratify their decision. And
part of this was to show the the
population, the Jews, that Jesus was a
criminal. Look, we went through the
proper procedure and even took him to
the Roman authorities. So, uh, they they
ratified what we said. And so, I bring
you also to Luke 4 29 and 30. And we're
going to take a look at the situation of
Stephen in a moment. In Luke 4:29 and
30, uh, it says, "And rose up." This is
a time when Jesus was was with the Jews.
And it says, "And they rose up and
thrust him out of the city and let him
unto the brow of the hill where on the
city was built that they might cast him
headlong, but he passing through the
midst of them went his way." So there
were a few times when the Jews tried to
kill Jesus uh without any let's call it
uh approval from the Roman authorities,
but his time had not come and that was
not allowed. Uh let's take a look at
Acts chapter 7. In Acts chapter 7 is
when Stephen is facing uh the scribes,
the Pharisees, the the the leadership of
the people of Israel. The situation is
very interesting. Stephen first tells
him part of the history of the Jews and
how God dealt with them. But notice Acts
chapter 7. Stephen is talking. He says,
"Which of the prophets did your fathers
not persecute? and they killed those who
foretold the coming of the just one of
whom you now have become the betrayers
and murderers who have received the law
by the direction of angels and have not
kept it. When they heard these things,
they were cut to the heart and they
nashed at him with their teeth. But he
being full of the Holy Spirit gazed into
heaven and saw the glory of God and
Jesus standing at the right hand of God
and said, "Look, I see the heavens open.
And the Son of Man standing at the right
hand of God. Then they cried out with a
loud voice stopped their ears and ran at
him with one accord, and they cast him
out of the city and stoned him." And the
witnesses laid down their clothes at the
feet of one young man named Saul. And
they stoned Stephen as he was calling on
God saying, "Lord Jesus, receive my
spirit." Then he knelt down and cried
out with a loud voice, "Lord, do not
charge them with this sin." And when he
has said this, he fell asleep. So what
is happening is here is that they were
really uh outraged. They were out of
control. Their anger, even beyond
reason, and this was an act of rage.
>> So the idea of going to get this
ratified, get this approved by the
Romans was not in their mind. This was
rage. And when you talk about Saul, what
did Saul do? In Acts chapter nine verse
one and two, it says, "Then Saul, still
breathing threats and murder against the
disciples of the Lord, went to the high
priest and asked letters from him to the
synagogues of Damascus, so that if he
found any of who were of the way,
whether men or women, he might bring
them bound to Jerus Jerusalem." So he
had letters, and with these letters, he
was able to do these things. And of
course there was fear because he had
some Romans or or some soldiers with
him. So there these are different things
>> things to consider.
>> Thank you so much. Thank you. Now we're
going to move on to the next question in
Shelly. Would you please answer Sharon
from Colorado? She sent in a text. Thank
you Sharon. Um the question is is Satan
here or locked up till later?
>> Oh Sharon. Satan is active on this earth
right now. He, the Bible describes him
in John 12:31 as the prince of this
earth. 1 Peter 5'8, he says he's a
roaring lion uh going around seeking
whom he may devour. In Revelation 12:10,
he says that he is the accuser of the
brethren. And you know, even Jesus said
that the thief comes not but to steal,
kill, and destroy. But he Jesus came to
give us abundant life. Satan is doing
everything he can to deceive, to divide,
to destroy
until his final judgments, which he
knows his time is short and it's coming
soon. So, he's here. He's active. He's
dangerous. Do not ignore Satan. But
here's the good news. Satan is on a
leash. His power can be resisted. If you
look at James 4:7, it says, "Submit to
God. Resist the devil and he will flee
from you. 1 John 4:4 says, "Greater is
he who is in you than he who is in the
world." So, Satan's final imprisonment,
you bet, it's coming. But let me tell
you, his destruction is also certain.
When will Satan be locked up? If we look
at Revelation 20:es 1-3, we find that
Satan is going to be bound for a
thousand years, which most people refer
to as the millennium after the second
coming of Christ. Now listen, it says,
"Then I saw an angel coming down from
heaven and he laid hold of the dragon
and bound him for a thousand years so
that he would deceive the nations no
more till the thousand years were
finished." That's kind of a condensed
version of Revelation 21 through3.
This binding
doesn't involve physical chains. This
binding represents a condition that
restricts Satan's activities after
Christ returns. What are the conditions?
The righteous have been taken to heaven.
We looked at that and well, that was
last program. is 1 Thessalonians
4:16-17.
The righteous have come up in the first
resurrection. The wicked have been
slain. Jeremiah 25:33, the New Testament
says they're destroyed by the breath of
his mouth. And the earth lies desolate
during those thousand years. That's what
Jeremiah 4:23-26
teaches us. So, Satan's left with no one
to tempt. He is bound by circumstances
in a prison of isolation and one where
he'll do some reflection after the
thousand years relief brief released
briefly then destroyed forever.
Revelation 20:20. So hold on Sharon.
Jesus has already won the victory and he
will soon crush Satan under your feet.
>> Amen. Amen. Praise the Lord.
>> All right. Well, we're moving on to the
next um question and this one is from
Jimma or Hima uh who sent in an email.
Now, this is what it says. In first king
18:40, why did Elijah slay the prophets
of Baal after they surrendered?
Commandment six says, "Don't kill." What
do you have to say about this, pastor?
>> Jimma, thank you so much for that
question. You mentioned the sixth
commandment found in Exodus 20:13.
You know, the King James Bible renders
that as thou shalt not kill,
>> but Moses used the Hebrew word rack,
which means to dash in pieces, that is
to kill a human being, especially
through murder. So the new new King
James translates it as as a murder. Thou
shalt not murder rather than thou shalt
not kill, just to start us off that way.
But let's look at this story about
Elijah. It's found in first kings like
you mentioned. Let's go to chapter 18.
And we'll begin with verse 20 to 21 and
onward. So Ahab sent all the children of
Israel and gathered the prophets
together onto Mount Carmel. This was
after the three and a half years of no
rain. So we're gathering up on top of
Mount Carmel for Carmel for a showdown.
And Elijah came unto all the people. Now
think of that to all the people who he's
come to. And he said, "How long halt ye
between two opinions? If the Lord be
God, follow him. But if Baal, then
follow him." And the people answered
him, "Not a word." Verse 39 says, "And
when all the people saw it," this is now
after that lightning came down and wiped
out, you know, took sucked everything
up.
>> And all the people uh saw it and they
fell on their faces and they said, "The
Lord, he is the God. The Lord, he is the
God." In verse 40, and Elijah said unto
them, take the prophets of Baal, let not
one of them escape.
>> So it doesn't sound like they had
surrendered. They're wanting to get
away. And they took them and Elijah
brought them down to the book Kishan and
slew them there. So the Hebrew word that
was translated into slew is shakat. And
it means to slaughter, like a sacrifice,
kill, slay. That's used 81 times in the
King James version. So we can picture
the scene on top of Mount Carmel with
Elijah and a huge crowd of Israelite
people. It's they're called people in
this text.
Let's say that they're the spectators
along with Ahab and possibly Ahab's on
his throne with servants providing him
shade and fanning him. And then you have
Elijah and the 450 prophets of Baal.
They're on display there. I don't know,
maybe on a mound higher than everybody
else. Or else everybody else is up high
and they're looking down one way or the
other. They're on display. these 450
prophets of Baal and then Elijah uh so
everybody can see him. It doesn't say
that the prophets of Baal fell on their
faces and shouted the Lord, he is the
God. So we can assume that they stood
defiantly and didn't bow in submission
to the creator God. And we can assume
that their hearts were hardened against
God. And I'm going to expound more on
that in the next question, my answer to
that further on this topic of hardening
of one's hearts. Uh verse 30 says, "And
Elijah said unto all the people, come
near unto me." And all the people came
near unto him, and he repaired the altar
of the Lord that was broken down.
Friends, I believe that we're living in
the middle of another showdown. And
we're on top of another Mount Carmel,
and we need to repair our own broken
down altars. We need to establish or
else reestablish our worship of God.
>> And let's make our calling and election
sure. Again, thank you for that
question.
>> Yes. Thank you, JMA. Thank you for that
email you sent in. Well, in Revelation
20 tells us that Satan and his followers
were cast into the lake of fire forever.
With this in mind, what is Revelation
22:15 about? The viewer from Oregon sent
in that text and John Dincy will answer
this question.
>> Well, by God's grace, we will endeavor
to do that. So, Revelation chapter 20 um
does bring this out that you have
mentioned. But we have to remember that
the book of Revelation is not
necessarily chronological in order as
you move on from one verse to another,
one chapter to another. In fact, there
were no verses and chapter separations
uh when the manuscript was written. But
let's go ahead and take a look at what
is happening here in Revelation chapter
20. Just as you said, Satan and his
followers are cast into the lake of fire
and it seems that it's over. Revelation
chapter 21 then talks about the new
Jerusalem and that the tabernacle of God
is with men and that he will wipe away
all tears from our eyes and there will
be no sickness, pain or death. And it
seems like it should be happiness
forever and ever and ever. Uh also when
you get to revelation 22, the first uh
five verses talk to us about practically
the same thing and about eating from the
tree of life. It is at Revelation 22:6
that we begin to see that Jesus
is we begin to see that it's talking
about the coming of the return of Jesus.
So it takes us uh back before the people
are tossed into the lake of fire.
Revelation 22 beginning in verse 12.
Notice what it says. It says, "And
behold, I am coming quickly. My reward
is with me to give everyone according to
his work." So, this is before the people
are cast into the lake of fire. So, it
it went back in time. And it says in
verse 13, "I am the Alpha and the Omega,
the beginning and the end, the first and
the last. Blessed are those who do his
commandments, that they may have the
right to the tree of life and may enter
through the gates into the city." So an
appeal is being made now to those that
are reading to obey God's commandments
to be faithful to repent so that they
will be able to enter into the city. And
what happens if you don't? If you don't
accept salvation, if you don't accept
Jesus Christ as your personal savior, if
you choose to disobey God's
commandments, it says in Revelation
22:12,
"But outside
are dogs and sorcerers and sexually
immoral and murderers and idolattors and
whoever loves and practices a lie." Now,
the dog lovers, please be uh please
understand this is a symbolical uh term
for wicked people. Uh so don't don't get
too too u upset about that here because
uh well let's continue here. Revelation
chapter 21.
>> Notice here that again uh after
Revelation 20 there's an appeal being
made to people reading the book of
Revelation. It says he who overcomes
shall inherit all things and I will be
his God and he shall be my son. But the
cowardly, unbelieving, abominable,
murderers, sexually immoral, sorcerers,
idolattors, and idolattors, and all
liars shall have their part in the lake
of fire, which burns with fire and
brimstones, which is the second death.
So here again, in Revelation 21, uh, you
have an appeal to repent. And in
Revelation 22, you also have an appeal
to repent so that you can enter into
God's kingdom.
>> Amen. Amen. And thank you, Lord, that he
gives us that opportunity to repent. All
right, folks. Well, Telma sent in an
email or Thelma. Um, the question is,
with the world being so vast, why did
God have people take, fight, and kill to
take over their lands? Why could a new
land be cultivated? Shelley, would you
please answer?
>> I will, Telma. And thank you for this
question. And God's original plan was
peace, not conquest. He gave the entire
earth to humanity as a gift. But over
the generations uh there were entire
nations that sank into rebellion and
violence and cruelty and immorality. So
while cultivating a new land may seem
ideal, God's goal wasn't land
acquisition. It was redemptive and
relationship. what he was doing. His
goal was to establish a covenant people
who through their influence could
influence the other nations reaching
them. And Canaan was strategically
located at the crossroads of three
continents. It was perfect place for his
people to be situated to reveal his
character and his law to a watching
world. It was not a random choice. This
is a land he had promised to Abraham in
Genesis 12:7. It's the land from which
the Messiah would come. This was the
promised land well before it was
inhabited by these others. And God did
not immediately give it to Abraham's
descendants. It's interesting if you
read Genesis 15, the instead what God
told Abraham is you're going to be
captive for 400 years. your people in
Egypt because he says in uh Genesis
15:16, the iniquity of the Amorites,
these are the people who lived in
Canaan, one of the groups, he said, is
not yet full. Well, how interesting.
What God was doing was giving them 400
years to repent for those Canaanites.
that they persisted in deep moral
corruption, child sacrifice according to
Deuteronomy 12:31, sexual perversion,
Leviticus 18, the occult and demonic
practices that they had in from and it's
explained in Deuteronomy 8:9-12.
So God extended mo uh mercy hoping that
they would return to him. And when they
when their wickedness got so entrrenched
that it was threatening future
generations, he acted not out of cruelty
but to preserve life and truth and the
plan of salvation. God's commands to
Israel to to do away with the Canaanites
wasn't about racial superiority or
conquest. It was to execute his judgment
and protect people from those evil
nations. Yet, even among the Canaanites,
as they're doing this, God
absolutely opened his heart and saved
those who responded to him. Think of
Rahab, the prostitute in Jericho. God
saved her.
>> You know, Ezekiel 33:1,
God says, "I have no pleasure in the
death of the wicked." Some people think
God's up there just looking and going,
"I'm going to get you. I'm going to zap
you." But no, God is saying, "Turn, turn
from your wicked ways." God's command to
displace the Canaanites was justice that
had been restrained by mercy. He used
Israel to bring judgment so that he
could preserve the knowledge of the one
true God amid pagan darkness. Here's
what I will say. God's ways are higher
than ours. We don't always understand,
but his character is consistent. He is
just. He is patient. He is merciful.
He's redemptive. And what the Old
Testament is describing is not genocide.
This is divine judgment that was
following the long-suffering mercy of
God. And it all pointed to Jesus who
came not to seize land but to give his
life.
>> Amen. Thank you, Shelly. All right,
Pastor Moricon. Uh Sarah from Colorado
sent in a text and this is what it says.
Did God determine that Satan could never
repent and be forgiven of his sins? If
God is love, how is it possible that he
ultimately plans to destroy Satan? Um, a
being created for good in service to
God? Sarah asked a question.
>> Well, that's a heavy question there,
Sarah, but good question. You know, um,
you know, God, like you mentioned, he's
the creator. He created Satan. Well,
Lucifer is what he was created as. But
um and you know the creator has certain
laws that he has set up actually in our
physi physical bodies just like the law
of gravity you know there's all kinds of
laws there and so one of the laws has to
do with um our genes you know in our
bodies here on this earth where we have
genes you know the DNA makes up its code
and all that that those are all laws
that are in our being and God made us
that way and he used DNA to manufacture
us. I don't know if he did that with
Lucifer or not. Everything on this
planet though, anything that's alive,
living is that code is the DNA code and
uses genes and so forth, except for some
things with RNA. But so according to
Ezekiel, this is something we do know.
Ezekiel 28:15, it says that God created
Lucifer with totally a totally selfless
character. Let's read it. Thou was
perfect in thy ways from the day that
thou was created till iniquity was found
in thee. So his character was like God's
character, totally selfless, thinking of
others. It's it's actually the law of
the universe. And you mentioned God is
love.
>> That's 1 John 4:8 and 16. Also, he that
loveth not knoweth not God, for God is
love. So everything about him is love.
when Satan entertained and then embraced
his selfish thoughts and resisted God's
love. And I can imagine that God pled
with him to turn around from the
direction that he was headed because God
knew the law that he had made created
him. He came to the point of no return.
Meaning that his genes no longer would
ever respond to the meaning they had
been receiving of God. God is saying
today in the day today is the day of
salvation. Mhm.
>> He's always saying, "Harden not your
hearts." So when he's saying, "Harden
harden not your hearts," that's in
Hebrews 3:15 and 4:7. This means there's
a point that we can get to.
>> Yeah.
>> And our hearts will no longer respond
>> to God's pleading voice of love.
>> You know, you may have seen this in
human relationships. If someone is
unfaithful to their wedding vows and
another person can only take so much
till their heart is hardened
>> and the meaning to their gene expression
changes. So we have the example of
Charles Manson, the cult leader and the
convicted murderer who consistently
showed a lack of remorse for his crimes
during his life and imprisonment. When
asked if he felt remorse, he famously
responded, "Remorse for what?" M
>> ahead of his trial, Manson stated, "I
don't have any guilt. There's a point of
no return where God's love has no more
meaning to that individual." So, if God
were to manipulate the gene expression
and force it to be selfless, it wouldn't
be love anymore.
>> Force and love just don't go together.
Forcing love is an oxymoron.
>> Yes.
>> Thanks for the question.
>> Thank you, Sarah from Colorado, for
sending in that text. And Pastor
Moriggoni, thank you so much for
answering that question. And the final
question for this hour, John Densy will
answer and this is when will the seven
last plagues take place?
>> The seven last plagues, you know, this
is something that brings fear upon
people
>> and that's a good question. I'm not sure
why you want to know. Uh the reason um
we will eventually find out. But the
seven last plagues when you go to the
book of revelation 14 6-2 there you see
the three angels messages these three
angels messages are the messages that
are presented to the world in these last
days that we are living in. And within
the the three angels messages is a clue
that helps us understand that a time is
coming when the mercy of God will end.
In in other words, the people the final
the final warning has been given to the
world to repent before these seven last
plagues come. Because when the seven
last plagues come, no one else no one
else will repent. Why? Because the Holy
Spirit has done the work through in the
hearts of people and through God's
messengers. And no one else will repent.
They no one else will accept. And so God
has to make the decision to bring out
the seven last plagues and punish
people. So in Revelation chapter 14 are
the three angels messages. I'm going to
read beginning in verse 9. Notice here.
Then a third angel followed them, saying
with a loud voice, "If anyone worships
the beast and his image, and receives
his mark on his forehead or on his hand,
he himself shall also drink of the wine
of the wrath of God, which is poured out
full strength into the cup of his
indignation." This is talking about
without mercy. All the judgments of God
have been with mingled with mercy. But
now this is without mercy. He shall be
tormented with fire and brimstone in the
presence of the holy angels and in the
presence of the lamb. And the smoke of
their torment ascends forever and ever,
and they have no rest day or night, who
worship the beast in his image, and
whoever receives the mark of his name.
Here is the patience of the saints. Here
are those who keep the commandments of
God and the faith of Jesus. A
distinction is being made here between
those that keep the commandments of God
and those that do not. those that do not
receive the wine of the wrath of God.
This is talking about the seven last
plagues. We are living in the time when
the three angels messages are being
preached in Revelation 18. You see again
the three angels message messages kind
of repeated and amplified. And notice
what it says in Revelation 18. Uh I'll
read maybe one one verse one, two, and
three. After these things, I saw another
angel coming down from heaven, having
great authority, and the earth was
illuminated with his glory. The message
goes to all the world. And he cried
mightily with a loud voice, saying,
"Babylon the great is fallen, is fallen,
has become a dwelling place of demons, a
prison for every foul spirit, and a cage
for every unclean and hateful bird. For
all the nations have drunk of the wine
of the wrath of her fornication. The
kings of the earth have committed
fornication with her. And the merchants
of the earth have become rich through
the abundance of her luxury. I have to
keep reading. And I heard another voice
from heaven saying, "Come out of her, my
people, lest you share in her sins, and
lest you receive of her plagues. for her
sins have reached to heaven. And God has
remembered her iniquities. Rendered to
her just as she rendered to you and
repay her double according to her works
in the cup of which she has mixed mixed
double for her. This is talking about
the seven last plagues. The appeal is
made. Come out of her my people so that
you you don't receive of the plagues.
When will this be when this message is
preached out? We cannot give you a date.
We can give you a a reference of event
that are taking place. so that you will
know these things are happening.
>> Amen. And this just makes us want to
keep going, but unfortunately the time
is up. So, we're going to take a pause
and we're going to be right back with
some final comments. So, remember, this
is your program and this is the platform
where you can hear the answers to your
questions, Bible questions. So, praise
the Lord for this opportunity. We're
going to take a pause and we'll be right
back.
>> If you're enjoying our 3BN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's Holy Word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bible qa3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
618-2283975.
That's 618-2283975.
[Music]
Be sure to include your name and where
you live and then watch through Bible
Q&A for answers from God's word.
>> Well, thank you. Thank you. Now is the
time where our panelists get a chance to
just say a few words of encouragement.
Shelley, ladies first. Go right ahead.
>> I just want you to know if you read the
Bible and you think how awful God was.
You don't know the God of love. If if
you really get to understand God's
character, all of these questions, we
can answer them because I mean, I used
to think awful things about God when I
read the Old Testament till I put on he
he broadened me my
>> perspective and I see him through a lens
of love. And now as I'm reading through
the Bible, he connects it all for me
where I understand God is so patient, so
kind, so loving. He says, "I am the
Lord. I change not. Jesus is the same
yesterday, today, and forever."
>> God loves you.
>> Amen. Pastor Motor Glenny.
>> Well, you know, we were looking at God
and his laws that he has set up as far
as uh our own salvation. You know, some
people might think, well, you're doing
scare tactics, you know, trying to say,
you know, if you put off your salvation
till like some people would do it to
their deathbed. Well, I'm just going to
live my life until I'm ready to die.
Then I'll give my life to the Lord. I've
heard people say that,
>> you know, I was in West Virginia for
about 40 years. I was allowed to go to
that.
>> But anyway, we don't really know. In
other words, we can our hearts, we we
think that we can get our hearts to
become a certain way. But always God's
warnings are just they're facts. He's
not trying to scare us. He's just
letting us know this is the facts.
>> Amen.
>> You can't change your own heart. It
takes Jesus and he's saying today is the
day of salvation. Harden not our hearts.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> Praise the Lord. And John didn't deny.
uh you know in 2 Peter chapter 3:9 it
says that God is not willing that any
should perish perish but that all come
to repentance. What a wonderful message
this is to consider. God does not want
you to perish. And if you don't want to
perish, remember that God loves you and
he will not cast anyone out that comes
to him. So you have an opportunity to
come to the Lord. He will receive you.
He will forgive you. He will bless you.
And you can have eternal life because of
Jesus Christ.
>> Amen. Amen. And all these words of
encouragement, I just want to encourage
you today. You can call our pastoral
department if you want to give your life
to the Lord. We're here to help you. God
bless you. We'll see you next time.
[Music]